[Musique]
ces chiffres mesdames et messieurs je ne
les oublierai jamais car ils ont modifié
mon existence ils m'ont permis de sortir
de ma zone de confort
faire sortir de mon imaginaire cette
idée folle de réunir des dames afin
qu'ils puissent exprimer sur leurs
droits et devoirs pendant six semaines
organiser un événement en tenant compte
des contraintes et des exigences
des différents sponsors et partenaires
45 minutes
convaincre un auditoire de 350 personnes
par un défilé d'oratrice remarquable et
remarquée
il faut dire que
lorsque je veux faire quelque chose
je me pose des questions
comment je peux réaliser en projet avec
succès alors que je n'ai que la fois
j'ai essayé de répondre à cette question
en essayant de définir la fois à mon
sens ma définition à moi la fois c'est
croire en quelque chose d'invisible tout
en étant persuadé de sa faisabilité
alors pour moi la foi est le premier
outil le premier partenaire pour donner
vie à son projet
moi elle m'a aidé oui l'a aidé à sortir
de ma zone de confort à la zone de
confort ma zone de confort je vous la
décrit plutôt
comme une sphère
plutôt agréable
réconfortante
visible mais à l'apparence stable
équilibré j'insiste le mot apparence
alors
une fois que j'ai défini la fois je me
rends compte qu'il faut que j'avance
mois aline je suis timide malgré mon
dynamisme apparent
mais il ya quelques années
j'ai découvert le tedx et je me suis dit
moi aussi je vais être speaker du tedx
oui comme paul eluard l'a dit il n'y a
pas de hasard et a que des rendez vous
en fait c'était une rencontre avec ma
destinée je me suis entouré de personnes
passionnées d'art oratoire de prise de
parole en public je me suis entouré de
personnes au leadership entre non j'ai
appris je me suis révélé à moi et aux
autres et aujourd'hui
je suis là
[Applaudissements]
laissez moi vous raconter
j'avais donc partager cette idée avec
certaines personnes de mon entourage il
faut dire que lorsque j'ai une idée en
tête je sais être très persuasive et je
sait trouver les mots et les animés de
cette énergie qui vous plongent moi dans
mon imaginaire et il est très difficile
d'en ressortir et de s'en défaire
rassembler des femmes aménager une salle
pour elle afin qu'ils s'expriment
et puis la fois toujours là la fois une
fois qu'on s'est entendue donc sur le
projet je sais où je vais
il faut réunir les parties prenantes
mais avant les parties prenantes il ya
une chose dont on est sûr qu'on veut
sortir de sa zone de confort ah c'est
l'incertitude c'est la seule certitude
que vous avez et puis vous avez des amis
sur lesquels vous pouvez toujours
compter amine émis aujourd'hui que
j'appellerai les ennemis
la peur
et le doute donc on est là on a le
projet la peur
et la fois et le doute
revenons à nos parties prenantes
je ne citerai pas ici uniquement les
personnes bienveillantes n'en gesterra
aussi celles qui n'ont aucun intérêt
pour le projet les indifférents voilà je
parlera aussi des pessimistes mais
attention ces personnes là elles sont
actrices clé principale du film sortir
de ma zone de confort les bienveillantes
vous ne devez pas les décevoir elles
sont votre moteur votre carburant
ont les uns différentes
ça tombe bien on ne peut pas plaire à
tout le monde chacun sa sensibilité
et les pessimistes vous n'avez qu'à leur
dire qu'ils ne risque rien n'a rien
six semaines rassembler réunir des dames
les maintenir ces dames qui se sont
intéressés aux calendes par un visuel un
texte des couleurs
et elle vous donne l'opportunité à vous
de vous exprimer là je dis pose à la
basse et vous qui a ménagé une scène
pour elle mais en fait c'est elle qui
vous donne l'opportunité de montres au
monde de quoi vous êtes capables
derrière chaque candidate un mentor
à de garoua de douala de bamako de tunis
de ouagadougou d'abidjan de cotonou
derrière chaque candidate une histoire
une force une énergie une femme unique
et aujourd'hui je profite de cette scène
aménagée pour moi pour le rendre un
vibrant hommage hommage à ces femmes qui
ont parlé qui parle et qui parleront
toujours
semaine après semaine comme un chapelet
qui s'égrènent mon avance dans le
concours des sélections cardinal demi
finale hinman
voilà les choses avancent
elles sont prises au jeu et cette
emprise mois mme électrisé j'avance
sereinement
et on est là au bout de six semaines je
suis fier c'est un exploit je suis parti
de là à l'a20 à un de l'inconnu aucun
venue de l'invisible opale pas vous
pouvez applaudir
merci merci merci sauf que là mesdames
et messieurs je viens de vous conter la
belle partie de l'histoire
on saute rappelez-vous l'incertitude nos
ennemis qui ne nous laisse pas la peur
et le doute
hélas on se pose des questions et si
j'échoue et si je n'y arrive pas et si
je tombe et si on se moque de moi la
peur qui vous paralyse lettres
et le doute qui vous obstrue l'esprit
mais pendant que vous vous posez toutes
ces questions et que nos ennemis vous
vois les yeux les faits sont là vous
vous êtes engagé vous êtes trempé
jusqu'au cou il faut investir il faut
louer la seule fonds propres faut
imprimer les visuels c'est joli à de
belles couleurs oui
mais non et puis un détail non des
moindres que vous devez gérer pendant
six semaines
le temps
où certains c'est le retard
pour d'autres c'est carrément les
absences et puis vous avez cet appel ce
sms lui à l'aube au jour madame allié je
voudrais juste vous prévenir le
malheureusement je ne pourrai pas
continuer l aventure
les désistements
vous êtes un leader et vous devez
répondre avec bienveillance
mais là une carte de moins dans votre
château de cartes et vous devez trouver
la solution là sur le programme déjà
entamés n'oublions pas le doute qui vous
tient la main et vous serre la main et
vous regarde droit dans les yeux aline
es tu sûre de vouloir continuer
à ce moment-là vous fermez les yeux
un aller retour rapide vers le passé la
zone de confort qui clignotent au rouge
et que vous dit à un moment je ne veux
plus de toit
vas-y tu as décidé de te séparer de moi
et là
après une profonde et grande inspiration
vous dites on fera avec ce qu'on a et on
le fera bien
mesdames messieurs sans même vous en
rendre compte vous venez de faire preuve
de résilience
le bilan on le fera à la fin on le fera
plus tard mais il faut avancer on ne
peut pas avancer son aptitude les
compétences et la lumière elle est au
bout du tunnel est très vite vous vous
rendez compte qu'il vous faut des mains
ou commencé à écrire aux sponsors aux
partenaires il faut les combattre il
faut les persuader faut les intéresser
ils ont les moyens vous avez les ide ils
ont la force et vous vous avez l'énergie
vous amèneront de abb ac et caméras etc
à terra ensemble tout n'est que
puissance mais
pour rester les pieds sur terre le
contrat est clair il vous donne votre
chance parce que vos mots votre attitude
ont convaincu madame alors votre équipe
et vous vous avez 45 minutes pour me
convaincre pas plus
je suis assise dans la salle au premier
banc comme ce soir les candidats
défilent tour à tour déclame leurs
discours et j'ai même l'impression de
les découvrir pourtant nous avions déjà
une histoire ensemble depuis six
semaines
et ce moment magique est d'autant plus
excitant lorsque je vois les partenaires
porter leur regard sur leur montre
sortir de sa zone de confort demande et
exige une grande maîtrise de soi et les
autres
qui a dit que ce serait facile
qu'il a dit
vous serez secoué bousculer on se
moquera de vous on ne vous fera pas on
ne vous entendra pas
mais vous avez le devoir de prendre la
bonne décision la peur vous habitera
c'est à millas elle vous habitera
45 minutes interminables incertitudes
impondérable dans chaque instant et ses
instants ne finissent pas
et là la dernière candidate annoncée par
l'animateur conclu son discours
le chronomètre donne son verdict combien
de temps
quarante peu miné ouf
le programme millimétré suivi de très
près par le comité d'organisation
la rigueur la discipline
dont je suis assise voilà très fier
je peux voir le sourire des sponsors et
ressentir la satisfaction des
partenaires je les fais mon rêve
rassembler les femmes afin qu'elles
s'expriment sur le droit et devoir
respecter les contraintes des
partenaires et des sponsors moi je dis
ce soir merci j'ai dit merci aux
candidates merci à l'auditoire merci à
la peur merci au comité d'organisation
merci à la fois merci au doute
merci à l'architecte
merci
mais
tenez vous tranquille
lorsque vous êtes dans cette position 45
minutes interminables
vous devez respirer ce que vous pouvez
aussi faire c'est que vous pouvez tendre
la main à vos amis parce qu'entre temps
rappelez-vous les actrices et
bienveillante elles sont là les
indifférentes les pessimistes elle vous
auront rejoint choses incroyables votre
club fall oui et vous savez pourquoi
parce que vous avez décidé de continuer
parce que vous avez décidé d'être
courageux parce que vous avez décidé de
vous déployez et de sortir de votre zone
de confort et encore le petit plus
malgré la difficulté et l'adversité le
bonheur se lira sur votre visage c'est
mon processus sortir de ma zone de
confort c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
micro à la main voilà
face à l'auditoire
qui a applaudi après le passage de
chaque candidate
je suis partagé entre la panique et la
joie
- la timide comment avais-je pu réunir
toutes ces personnes les sortir de mon
imaginaire est resté là assise bien et
elle face à moi visiblement contente du
résultat
mais je vais vous dire jusque là tout
n'est pas terminé ah non pas ce que vous
pourriez perdre la voix
l'émotion vous pourriez vous épanouir
et là ce ne serait pas faire non ce
serait faire deux pas en arrière à côté
la zone de confort serait un paradis ce
serait parti dans le no go zone dans
cette zone là on en reparlera une autre
fois mais on reste serein
moi les mots me manquent et les paroles
sans sortie parce que ma bouche été
ouverte oui je l'avais fait la lumière
au bout du tunnel j'ai réalisé mon rêve
j'ai vécu mon rêve je suis allé jusqu'au
bout malgré les difficultés je peux vous
dire qu'au début personne n'y croyait
ce que je peux dire ce soir mesdames et
messieurs
c'est que j'ai eu peur
j'ai eu des doutes
j'ai toujours peur
j'ai toujours des doutes
j'aurais peur
j'aurai encore des doutes est ce qui a
changé
malgré mon dynamisme apparent je reste
quelqu'un de timide c'est qu'en plus de
compter sur mon premier partenaire
rappelez vous la fois désormais je
consulte mais désormais amis la peur et
le doute pourquoi parce qu'ils
m'envoient des signes et ce sont des
signes que je dois pouvoir être capable
de décrypter afin de prendre la bonne
décision en fonction de la circonstance
en face de moi
un processus douloureux
oui il faut se dépasser à chaque fois
mais fructueux parce que j'ai gagné de
la confiance en moi cette expérience m'a
permis d'acquérir des compétences
organisationnelles de gagner des valeurs
humaines et de la rénommée
sans la résilience
et sans ce processus
jenny se réparer alors ce que je
voudrais dire à toi dans la salle qui à
ce business plan oui je sais dans un
tiroir de son bureau je pense qu'il est
temps de le ressortir
à toi dans la salle qui a vide se
projeter dans l'agriculture je pense
qu'il est temps de lancer à toi dans la
salle qui a envie d'écrire un livre à
toi dans la salle qui a envie d'ouvrir
un restaurant à toi dans la salle à toit
dans la salle tout ce que je peux te
dire ses sorts et déploie toi
l'inconfort et la douleur
ce malaise m'ont donné envie de sortir
de ma coquille ça devenait insupportable
je vous ai dit que j'étais timide mais
je ne vous ai pas tout dit
j'étais timide et j'étais celle qui
proposait qui donnait les idées mais qui
n'arrivait pas à les assumer je n'étais
qu'à ligne
12 j'allais pouvoir réunir 350 personnes
400 personnes 500 personnes dans une
salle doux mais cet inconfort ce
mal-être et cette énergie dans mon
ventre qui a bouillonné pendant des
années cette voix qui me parlait mais tu
peux le faire qu'est ce qui t'arrive
ce que j'ai commencé par faire c'est à
ce moment là qu'il faut prendre des
notes
ce que j'ai commencé par faire
c'est qu'il faut identifier ses peurs
moi ma peur à moins en plus d'être
timide c'est que je n'assumais pas mes
idées
c'était ça ma peur alors chers poids
identifie tu as peur et lorsque tu
l'aurais identifié ce sera la première
scène de ton film sortir de ma zone de
confort et une fois que tu leur as fait
tu vas te retrouver face à des nouvelles
situations ne panique pas
tu vas avoir de nouvelles compétences et
là c'est la zone d'apprentissage une
fois dans le feu de l'action je peux
t'assurer que la timidité s'en ira très
loin mais contrée lointaine qui sera
pris par le feu de l'action tu auras
agrandi la zone de confort pour
atteindre la zone de grandeur celle dans
laquelle je suis
oui tout ce chemin pour faire 1 p dicks
tout ce chemin pour me retrouver devant
vous ça fait quatre ans j'ai organisé
des concours je me suis entouré des
personnes passionnées d'art oratoire
j'ai rencontré deux belles personnes
extraordinaires
je suis parti sénégal je suis parti à
douala je suis parti ap dicks garoua
tout ce chemin pour ça c'est mon rêve
sortir de ma zone de confort merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]